[Music]
instead of doing a video based on zelda
lore i want to go back to my roots for a
change
this channel saw its inception as a
place where i discuss gameplay elements
and
in particular dungeon mechanics and
that's what we're gonna be doing today
the idea for this video was inspired by
a modder by the name of waikutero
who not too long ago premiered the first
large-scale custom dungeon for breath of
the wild
now i'm not supposed to promote mods but
it exists
and i do think it's fair and harmless to
use it as a case study
i've already talked about the divine
beasts and shrines extensively
so i'm not going to repeat myself again
and will instead refer you to my very
first video which covers all my praises
complaints and suggestions about them
what i want to do here is take a look at
some specific dungeon mechanics
and see which ones i think should go
which ones are worth bringing back
and potentially expanded or altered for
the highly anticipated sequel to breath
of the wild
some things i won't be covering are
enemies and bosses specific dungeon
items and aesthetics i want to purely
focus on aspects like puzzle mechanics
tools for navigation quality of life
improvements and other topics revolving
around progression
challenge or traversal so let's dive
right in
let's start off with a simple quality of
life improvement reducing scripted
camera events
if there's one thing i really dislike
about revisiting the older 3d games
it is the constant need to freeze you in
your tracks and show you what you've
just accomplished or give you hints
about the room you just entered
even if it's something you've already
done many times before
opening a door changing water currents
or water levels
manipulating any other aspects of the
dungeon heck even showing you the same
unnecessary cutscene for switches you've
been pulling or hitting since the very
beginning of the game
we get it we hit the ice switch and it
closes we also don't need to see a door
opening every time we defeat all enemies
or solve a puzzle in a room
taking control away from the player like
this constantly might have felt
necessary in the old days when we were
still getting used to navigating a 3d
space
but nowadays it's just wasting your time
i get that in some cases when you do
something significant it looks cool and
cinematic to show parts of the dungeon
changing but this should only be
reserved for big events and only the
first time you trigger it
breath of the wild already handled this
concept way better when you manipulate
the divine beast from the map screen it
doesn't show you a cutscene of the
dungeon moving
it just happens and you can observe the
effects while still having freedom of
movement
triggering switches doesn't always show
you exactly what changed in the room
it's up to you to look around and
observe what the effects are
but the game does have the tendency to
fall into the old habits at times too
for instance unless the trigger to a
door is right in front of it and
impossible to miss
it still feels the need to show you the
door opening it still needs to play a
cutscene each time a chest
opens after clearing up a cobbling camp
something which should become obvious
after the first few times sometimes it
shows you something changing in a room
sometimes it doesn't it isn't always
consistent at handling it
it's already a huge step up from the old
games but i think it could be taken
further there are plenty of alternatives
to provide the player with information
without stopping them in their tracks
we already have the classic fanfare
which plays whenever you do something
significant
and in a lot of cases the sound of a
door opening should already suffice to
communicate to the player that they
succeeded
especially if the room you're in only
has one way in and out
on top of that you could do something
other games have done in the past and
show the cut scene of the door opening
in a small separate window in the corner
of the screen
or if you have access to a mini-map just
show something like a blinking icon
indicating where a door has opened
the freedom found in breath of the wild
is one of its greatest strengths
and is one of the aspects which got the
most praised by players and critics
alike
but in my opinion there is such a thing
as too much freedom
at least in terms of dungeons now for
the overworld the freedom worked and was
a nice change of pace for the series
which in the past
barred off large sections of the
overworld because you weren't supposed
to be there yet
this felt like hand-holding and after so
many games started to become very
formalic
but for dungeons this is a different
story a lot of people use hyrule castle
as a prime example
of how dungeons could or should have
been and while i think it's an amazing
place to explore
i would be hard-pressed to point to it
as a poster child for the sequel the
reason being that it's simply too
open-ended to function as a proper
dungeon reaching the boss should be
an ordeal a difficult but satisfying
road to success
something that's simply missing from the
castle since you can skip almost all of
it if you feel like it
placing restrictions on the player and
forcing them through a trial of rooms
puzzles and enemies
isn't always a bad thing that isn't to
say that there shouldn't be optional
sections
i'm all for rewarding the player for
some additional exploration that isn't
mandatory
but having 95 of the whole layout be
completely optional
is a bit too much for my taste i would
definitely want to find some middle
ground here
this also ties into the idea of having
all the tools needed to tackle each
dungeon from the very get-go i don't
know about you but i actually like
stumbling upon a dungeon which i'm
unable to beat or even enter
right away one that requires an item or
key which is found in a different
dungeon or maybe obtained through a
seemingly unrelated side quest somewhere
in the overworld
you will make a mental note of it and
continue on with your adventure but you
will always have that location in the
back of your mind
and you can't wait for the day that you
finally find what you need to enter and
look forward to seeing what's inside
what challenges await you and the cool
stuff you might find in there
dungeons can still be tackled out of
order but some might require
overcoming a different challenge first
not every dungeon needs to be accessible
right away
the best example of this is found in the
original on the nes
a game which breath of the wild took the
most inspiration from
the first three dungeons can be entered
and even completed out of order but
there are also some later in the game
which require finding a specific item
first
freedom is nice but some restrictions
should also be in place to create this
anticipation
something to mark on your map and keep
in the back of your mind
speaking of maps let's talk about the
map historically maps in video games
have either been
close to useless or absolutely crucial
to keep track of where you've been
in the zelda series this kinda differs
from game to game
in some installments i barely even look
at the map and finding it gets nothing
more than a
meh out of me other times like in the
example of skull woods or ganon's tower
in a link to the past
the dungeon is so convoluted and
disconnected with a huge part of it
being completely optional that finding
the map is actually very convenient
i think breath of the wild took it a
step too far turning the map into a
glorified gps
being able to see exactly where you are
in real time is convenient
sure but it also kinda takes away from
the mystery if you already know exactly
what lies beyond a certain room or
corridor
this goes especially for hyrule castle
as somehow we have a map of the entire
structure from the moment of entering we
never even had to acquire it and in the
divine beast getting the map is the
first thing you are forced to do
since without it you cannot manipulate
the dungeon and thus you are unable to
access
most of it and progressing through the
dungeon just becomes a follow the dots
at that point
i would personally want to revert back
to the old map style but at the same
time i would also make some changes to
it
i do think it's nice that the map
highlights which room you are currently
in like in the old games but seeing your
exact position within each individual
room
is a bit much the same thing goes for
being able to see every treasure chest
on the map
after obtaining the compass which also
kinda takes away from the mystery
in fact i would go as far as to say that
the compass can be excluded altogether
something breath of the wild already did
away with however treasure chests inside
the dungeons were handled
quite poorly this had everything to do
with the fact that after clearing a
divine beast you are no longer allowed
to re-enter it and because of this none
of the chests hold anything substantial
no unique apparel weapons or upgrades at
least nothing you wouldn't eventually be
able to find or buy in the overworld
since not obtaining all chests inside
the beast during your first playthrough
would mean you would never be able to
100
the game that being said it would be
nice if you could somehow keep track of
which doors are locked but rather than
showing this from the very beginning i
would go the silent hill route and only
show that a door is locked after you've
already encountered it we could even go
a step further
instead of link automatically making
notes of this on the map
this responsibility could be handed to
the player in the past we've seen this
in phantom hourglass and spirit tracks
where you can actually draw on your map
now obviously without a touch screen and
a stylus this would be very inconvenient
so instead i would just use the stamp
mechanic from breath of the wild
overworld map
i mean why fix what isn't broken the
player could mark locations of chests
keys locked doors or any other important
findings themselves
and the best thing about it is that it's
completely optional if you have a good
memory or don't feel like fiddling
around with the map
you don't have to i also think that the
map would be given more meaning if it's
something well hidden and isn't always
handed out early on
finding it should be something
significant after wandering around
without a clue of what the dungeons
layout actually looks like
you finally have something to hold onto
something to help you orient yourself
this should never be a given which leads
into the next subject
if there's one thing that the 3d
installments are guilty of when it comes
to dungeons
is that they tend to fall into the same
habit of giving you everything in a set
order
making it all feel very formulaic i
actually forgot to mention this in my
video about the beauty of 2d zelda games
for that video specifically i decided to
revisit the nes original
oracle seasons and a link to the past
and one of the first things i was
reminded of was the variation in its
progression
sometimes you find the main item very
early on other times
close to the end sometimes you find two
items or the item you find isn't needed
to beat the dungeon
in some rare cases the item needed isn't
even found inside the dungeon but in the
overworld somewhere and the boss door
doesn't always lead straight to the boss
but rather
unlocks a whole new section breath of
the wild too could definitely learn from
this and might even be able to take it a
step further
not every dungeon needs a main item or
even a map
going back to silent hill for a moment
some of the maps or better weapons in
the quote-unquote dungeon sections of
the game are so well hidden that some
players never even find them and simply
soldier through without them
some areas purposely don't have a map
where the protagonist draws his own as
he ventures from room to room if a place
is supposed to be
a maze handing the player a map kinda
defeats the purpose
i'm sure you all have your own examples
and experiences with games which handle
things differently
and how it sparks the mystery and
satisfaction of finding out on your own
where you are and what you need to
venture further
it is at that point that a dungeon stops
feeling like a video game level with
predetermined rules and more like an
actual place you are exploring the
feeling of being the first in a long
time to set foot within its walls and
discover its secrets and history
lastly i will touch upon the aspect of
survival some consider breath of the
wild's overworld to be the biggest
dungeon in zelda history while i
wouldn't exactly call it as such myself
i do think dungeons could learn from
breath of the wild's overworld where you
don't just smash your way through them
a dungeon should feel like a
self-contained adventure in and of
itself
a dangerous place where you might be
stuck for quite some time and you need
to make do with what you brought in with
you
or find inside this presents the idea of
dungeons having certain safe spots
places to rest cook food or catch your
breath for a while
similar to the rooms found in the trial
of the sword a safe space where there's
no enemies and you can just hang out for
a bit while you plan your next route or
move
these rooms could also double as a place
to save your game
generally in breath of the wild you can
save your game anytime and anywhere you
want but there are some exceptions like
event island and the aforementioned
trial of the sword where the game
restricts you from saving mid challenge
of course i wouldn't go as far as not
being able to save at all while being
inside of a dungeon hence why safe spots
to do this
could be a nice option it's never been
done in a zelda game before
but it has in games like dark souls
where the bonfires act as save and spawn
points for the player
there's something about overcoming a
dangerous challenge and breathing a sigh
of relief when you finally find a place
to rest and save your progress
it also makes a game over a lot more
significant if you haven't found a safe
spot in a while
making the dungeon more challenging in
the process and while we're on the topic
of challenge and survival
let's talk about healing though this
isn't necessarily a mechanic unique to
dungeons alone i do think it has a
pretty big impact on it
it's a complaint that many have already
pointed out when the game was still
brand new
and that is that being able to heal
yourself from within the menu
is just too overpowered i think this
mechanic definitely deserves an overhaul
in breath of the wild too
at first breath of the wild seemed
intimidating because enemies had a much
higher damage output than in previous
titles
and on top of that hearts were
completely eliminated from the game
but in reality the food mechanic means
you are carrying a huge collection of
hearts with you at all times
there should definitely be a much bigger
restriction on it some of these
restrictions could include limiting the
amount of food you can devour in a
certain time span
making your hearts restore gradually
upon eating instead of filling them all
up instantaneously
or perhaps most effectively just go to
dark souls route and turn the healing
process into something real time and not
something you can just do from the menu
screen
one or more of these measures should do
the trick and i cannot wait to see link
desperately running from a lino while
trying to stuff a roasted chicken
into his mouth and with that i will
conclude this video
as you can see from the points i've
covered some dungeon mechanics were
already improved in breath of the wild
but if the sequel were to go back to the
more traditional dungeon style
there's definitely something to be
learned from the old but also from the
new approach
breath of the wild's open-ended nature
might have been a step too far when it
came to dungeons but the same thing goes
for the more formulaic and restrictive
construction found in the older games
as mentioned before a middle ground
would be the key i want to thank
waikuteru for giving me permission to
use some of his footage
if you want to see more regarding the
subject of dungeons i've made a couple
of videos on the topic of progression
items
dungeon traversal preparation aesthetics
and atmosphere
etc which can be found in the
description as well as links to
waikatero's videos on his channel
as always a big thanks to my amazing
patreons channel members and the folks
on my discord who all work together to
make it a lively place to be
additionally a quick shout out to merlin
cooads for upgrading their pledge on
patreon
and to coocolover for doing an amazing
job arranging all the new discord
functionality
thank you all so much for the help and
support i will see you all in the next
video this is dawn signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you